o las jons en el gobierno anterior bajo
angela merkel fue el ministro de
finanzas entonces creo que sí va a haber
una continuidad en el tema de una
solidez financiera pero sí va a haber
cambios y se habla mucho en alemania de
esta transformación en la gobernanza que
significa impulsar modernizar alemania
en temas de digitalización innovación
pero pero también en tecnologías verdes
y yo creo que este va a ser la huella
que va a querer poner la coalición
semáforo cuáles podrían considerarse los
mayores logros de merkel en sus 16 años
en la cancillería
aunque la merkel fue sin duda la
canciller que maneja que enfrenta y que
propone soluciones a las crisis su
carácter la forma en la que ella
resolvió las diferentes crisis en las
que se enfrentó como la financiera la
del euro la de los refugiados ahora la
de la pandemia hace que angela merkel
dejes a alemania con una alta
popularidad y también a leer
no se pueden dejar de entender a una
alemania sin con angela merkel debido a
su estabilidad angela merkel el logro en
16 años tener a una alemania estable
pero faltó llevar a cabo las reformas
para hacer de alemania un país más
atractivo bueno pues a usted muchísimas
gracias por compartir este análisis con
nosotros en france 24